Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Getting Over It with Bennett Foddy.
This game is gonna be totally fair,
not rage-indicuing at all,
and I'm gonna keep my sanity in this!
[Piano music begins]
(I'm good at this I swear)
Everything is fine...v(｡-_-｡)v
Everything is fine.(￣^￣)ゞ
Everything is fine...o(╥﹏╥)o
See, I'm pretty good at the game. Okay, I-Im pretty-I'm pretty good at the game-｡◕‿◕｡
[Le Gasp]
nOoOoOoO.ヘ(゜Д、゜)ノ
Any lost progress is a(n) opportunity to-succEEEEEED AGAINNNNNNN! [Marks voice fades out]
[O O F]
(Please just end my suffering...)
I've learned things, but they don't help me.(╯︵╰,)
Nothing can help me...(oT-T)尸
Just--
Let this be a bad dream.
[Cri]
I'm gonna cry!｡･ﾟﾟ･(>д<)･ﾟﾟ･｡
I'm gonna cry because you're sUCH A PIECE OF SHI-
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA!!!1!1
ヘ(゜Д、゜)ノ
I don't want anything else for Christmas.ʕ•̫͡•ॽु✚⃞ྉ*✲ﾟ*｡⋆
I just wanna get back to where I was.
(Well, I mean, he went back...)
o O H
F U C k ! !
(NoT rAgE iNdUcInG aT aLl)
OH MY GOD!(ノಠ益ಠ)ノ
I'M DONE! OH GOD!!ヽ(#ﾟДﾟ)ﾉ┌┛
FUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUCK!!!!凸(｀0´)凸
OH MY GOD!!!(ノಠ益ಠ)ノ彡┻━┻
[Muffled Frustrated Screaming]
WHAT
THE FUCK
[Inhale]
WAS
THAT!?｡゜(｀Д´)゜｡
Bennet: "You cannot now believe that you will ever feel better. You are sure to be happy again. Knowing this, will make you less miserable now."
-Abraham Lincoln
Shut up Abraham Lincoln, I hate you so much. [O O F]
(fuck it all)
This game is fascinating in that, it makes me exceptionally angry,
but at the same time, it's understandably
my fault.(︶ω︶)
I-It's-It's understa-oOooOoh Ahhᕦ(ò_óˇ)ᕤ
[Chica saves the day ▽・ω・▽]
[Bork]
Hi Chica! Who's a good puppy?
(Don't chica)
What are you doing?
W H A T   A R E   Y O U   D O I N G ! ?
[Chica says no]
[Slow-Motion] NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
Chica: Long live the king. >:^)
[Calming Piano Music in Contrast to Imminent Death]
[Death Incoming]
[Mark Screaming]
[R.I.P. Mark Edward Fischbach (1989-2018)]